in an ever-expanding sea of information
finding the right content to satisfy
your Cravings has become an overwhelming
task whether it's seeking the perfect
movie diving into a captivating book
exploring new music genres or
discovering exciting products the sheer
abundance of choices can leave us
feeling lost and frustrated that's where
recommender systems come to a rescue
like trustee guides leading us through
multiple options opening doors to
Uncharted Tire trees that align
perfectly with the interest and
preferences the commander systems have
swiftly emerged as the unsung heroes of
the digital age offering personalized
suggestions that go beyond entire
guesswork powered by Advanced algorithms
and machine learning these intelligent
systems have revolutionized how we
navigate vast online platforms
Transforming Our digital experiences
into seamless journeys of exploration
and satisfaction at their core
recommender systems are the hidden
engines driving the success of today's
most prominent platforms from streaming
services like Netflix Spotify and
YouTube to e-commerce Giants such as
Amazon and Alibaba these systems have
become indispensable tools for curating
personalized content recommendations
that keep us engaged and attained and
coming back for more but how do these
systems work their magic
through a complex interplay of data
analysis pattern recognition and user
feedback recommended systems unlock the
power of collective intelligence with
that in mind join us on a journey into
the fascinating world of machine
learning with our Caltech postgraduate
program in Ai and ml in partnership with
IBM this AIML course covers the latest
tools and Technologies from the AI
ecosystem and features master classes by
Caltech faculty and IBM experts
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
this program showcases Caltech ctm is
excellence and IBM's industry progress
the artificial intelligence course key
Concepts like statistics data science
with python machine learning deep
learning NLP reinforcement learning and
through an Interactive Learning model
with live sessions enroll now and unlock
exciting Ai and ml opportunities the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below with that having
said hey everyone welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel but before we
dive into that don't forget to like
subscribe and share and discover the
inner workings of the these intelligent
engines and unveil the secrets behind
their uncanny ability to anticipate our
desires let's delve into The Cutting
Edge techniques and challenges that
shape the future of personalized
Discovery and unravel how recommended
systems shape and how we navigate the
vast ramps of information and
entertainment in the digital era now
over to our training experts so at first
we will import some major libraries or
python which will help us in
mathematical functioning so
so the first one is numpy import
numpy as NP
so number is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in the domain of
lineal algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
so here NPD in NPS denoting numpy so we
will import the next Library
both
pandas as
PD
is should be space yup
so pandas is a software Library written
for the Python programming language for
data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structures and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and time series so
after importing libraries we will move
ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write
like we have two data set with us
let me show you the data set we have two
data set with us
the first one is credits
this one
and the second one is movies one
movies one so don't worry you can get
these data set link in the description
box so let me write
here
credits
let's go data frame equals to PD dot
read
underscore CSV
here you have to give your location of
the data set
edits
dot CSV
the second one is movies
let's go
data frame
this is for movie data frame PD dot
treat
so here you have to give the movie
location movie data set location movies
dot CSV
okay everything seems good
let me run this
yeah
so then
here PD is for the pandas Library read
is used for reading the data set from
the machine and CSV is used for the type
of file which you want to read so after
this let's write code to see the data
set so we will write here credits
underscore DF
and we will run it so this is our so
this is our credit data set and next one
is movies
underscore
so this is our movie data set
so this is how our board data set look
like so here you can see three dots
this one and here also
this one
so we are unable to see our full data
set like what if we want like full a4803
rows
so at that case we can write here
PD Dot
set
underscore option
okay
and here we will write display
dot Max
underscore columns
this
and here we will write none
same for the rows PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
underscore rows
okay
none
let's run this
so now if we will write credits
underscore DF
it is running yeah
so now you can see your full data set
like full credit data set with 4803 rows
or four eight zero two rows because
there is
this is starting from zero that's why so
what about movies data set
okay wait running
it is still running you can see here
so here you can see the full data set
movie data set with 4802 rows
or if you want to see only five top rows
so you can write here credits underscore
DF dot hat
so by this
only five top rows so from head you we
can see our five top rows and if we will
use tail instead of head we can see our
last five rows so here let me do with
the movies one
DF Dot
tail
yeah
so here you can see four seven nine
eight row four seven nine and Del four
eight zero two so we'll tell we can see
our last five rows
so moving forward let's merge that
credit data set to movie data set
because if we will combine them the
confusion will be less and at the end it
will be better for us so we will write
here movies
underscore
equals to movies
underscore data frame and credits
underscore DF
on
it okay T is small I guess yeah perfect
there's Titan
so let me do something something like
this
okay
it is saying data frame object is not
callable
edits underscore DF
please
okay why because
we haven't wrote merge here
now it will work
yeah perfect it's working so data is
merged let's see the number of rows and
column using share function so now we
have only one so movies underscore DF
dot shape
okay let's run it 4809 and 2 3 23 but if
we see here like in movies data set so
in movies data set here here yeah yeah
there are 20 and
in here we are four columns in credit
data set
so
like so you will be thinking that's why
not 24 why only 23 columns that is why
on title you can see here on title the
titles in both titles are same you can
see here
both titles are same
in both
let me show you like this okay after
Pirates of the Caribbean Spectra and so
on here you can see after pirates of the
academy inspector and so on
so that is why on title
written while merging so title are same
so moving forward let's see our merge
data set
so we will write only movies
underscore data frame dot head
yeah
so our data is merged you can see
the last cast crew movie ID yeah you can
see here movie ID title are the same
they are most cast crew okay guys
let me give some more
for the better View
yeah
so you can see all Columns of credit
data set are added to movies one so
moving forward let's see another
function like
movies
underscore DF Dot info
so by this
yes you can see
so by this the data frame information is
printed via the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use rage
index and the number of cells in each
columns like non-null values note that
info method does indeed print the
information
so here you can see the all the
information is printed
okay
like columns name and the all null
values count and data types to like this
int object and
in which we are working most so after
this let's move forward and select some
main column in which you are working
most so we will write movies
underscore DF equals to movies
underscore DF
title
comma and another one is overview
okay why
okay here we have to get like this
yeah
so here we have to write John R
Jonah is complete and we will work on
what keywords keywords are the main
keywords okay keywords then
it will cost
then we will
we will do recommendation with the crew
as well
okay
by running this let me see
our data again with seven okay okay
there is one error okay this is movie
the movie The Idea yeah not index okay
got it got it
why not Jonah
it's Jonas I guess
what it is it's John it's
that's why
it's Jonas okay
yeah so let's see our data again with
seven columns so I will write so I will
write here movies underscore DF
dot head
here
so you can see only our we have like
movies ID same title overview genres
keywords cars and crew only
so here you can see the selected columns
okay so let's move forward and once
again let's see the info again like
movies
underscore TF Dot
invoice come with selected columns and
let's move forward and see how many
missing values are present in particular
column so like the columns is full we
can see here but we don't know about
that four thousand eight zero three
values are filled or not so what we will
do it we will see how many missing
values are present there so
here we will write like movies
underscore DF dot is null
dot sum
not like this
yeah perfect
so the function data frame is null this
one is null dot sum dot sum Returns the
number of missing values in the data set
so here you can see overview have three
missing values
so what we can do is we can write here
movies
underscore DF
DF
Dot
drop n a
this
equals to
true
okay
we will run it with sayings okay words
documents
also true okay fine
dot underscore drop in it and yeah it
will not create an issue so if you sat
in place equals to true the drop any
method will modify your data frame
directly that means that if you set in
place equals to true the drop any will
drop all missing values from your
original data set let's move forward and
see
movies
underscore DF
Dot
duplicated
so the duplicate method returns a series
with true on false
values that describe which rows in the
data frame are duplicated or not use the
subset parameter to specify if any
column should not be considered when
looking for duplicates
so
here let me run this first
so here we are we are getting 0. y 0 so
if you are like thinking there is no
true or false return so if you write it
without sum like if I will write it
without some
okay let me copy from here yeah and I
will run this so
here you can see
false false false in whole data set
so some will combine them and return you
a value at the end zero represent false
itself
so we need to not need this so we will
write something else
so moving forward let me write First
movies
underscore TF dot I location
Dot johnnets
let me run this
so the I log function this one ilock
function
first let me do something like this
it will go up okay huh
Okay so
from ilock function in Python is defined
in the pandas module that helps us to
select a specific row or column from the
data set
using the ilock method in Python we can
easily retrieve any particular value
from a row or column by using index
value so here zeroth position line is
coming
which is here you can see
so name action like name action name
Adventure name fantasy this side
physician
this one science fiction yeah so this is
because I am giving here Jonah that is
why you can see here
see ID 28 name action name something
something like that okay
so
let's import something called ASG
abstract syntax Factory
so this is one of the major Library
import AST
let me run this import is a class
defined is the AST module that is used
to express the import statement in
python in the form of abstract syntax
tree so
so an abstract syntax tree or just
syntax tree is a tree representation of
the of the abstract syntactic structure
of text written in a formal language
each node of the trade denotes a
construct occurring in the text
so let's convert some like literal to
object and append them so here I will
write Def
convert
obj object
like l
equals to
blank array
for I in
St Dot
Central
bit
e b
J object
okay
l dot append
return
here we are converting is like here is a
convert is a function and L is the array
to append by using for Loop we can
append them to name so let me write code
then I will explain like what is
happening so let me write full code so
movies
underscore TF
honors
okay because your movies
Donuts
and then dot apply
what
so then movies underscore TF
then I will write keywords
let's do movies
underscore DF
keywords
reply
Discord DF Dot
foreign
and that's keyword this keyword
apps ID name and so on like ID that name
like this type of things so it will
create a message retrieving them so by
using AST Library we just convert them
to the normal one like title so got it
guys so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
attributing again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
type of questions regarding any code or
something
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so moving forward let's convert cash to
and like same as previous way like like
this only
so what we will do here we will write f
convert
um
here I am using
so l equals to
counter equals to zero
St
dot literal
if counter
does not
equals to 3
then
l dot
dot append okay then here I have to
write I
to name
counter
equals to 1.
if you want to write like count as
equals to counter plus one it is like
both the same
else
click
done
well
so let me run this
let me run this
okay so after there's a small code we
have to assign the values like
we are doing it for Costner so movies
okay moves let's go DF then cast
let's show movies
underscore DF
asked
Dot
lie
convert
everything seems good
so let's see the changes are visible or
not so we will write here movies
underscore TF dot hat
you can ignore this like this is nothing
so here you can see cast is also
same like keyword and journal so like
let's do for the creo2
so like we are converting you can say in
a structured way
so let's do for the crew one two so let
me put some
yeah
so here we will add depth like fetch
which is nothing like a function name as
director
obj
colon l equals to
or I
n s t Dot literal
obj
if
I
like go
also is equals to
like we can hit director
so then
l dot append
um
dot append to the same name
but
return
okay capital l
so we have to again write that movies
video
equals to movies
in crew
lie
h
just remember fetch director is a
function name let's see changes
so here I have to write movies then
press enter so yeah crew is all set so
changes are visible and data is looking
good so what we
like if I want to see the first movie
Avatar overview this like this dot dot
dot so I have to write here
like movies
overview
Overview at 0th place
so yeah
so this is a full overview of Avatar
movie like let me read for this in this
2017 Century uh paraplegic Marine is
dispatched and blah blah blah blah and
civilization
so moving forward that what we want to
recommend movie in the basis of overview
genre keyword cash so for that we need a
separate separate words like in the then
22nd century alone
so if you will see in other columns all
the words are separated but like here if
you will see all the words are separated
like action is separated Adventure is
updated fantasy it's separated
so
there is a long sentence in this this
one in the overview one there's a long
sentence
so it's difficult to recommend from this
so what we are going to do is well we
will separate them like like other
columns so here we will write
movies
overview
let's do movies
and overview
and Dot apply
my bad sorry
then Lambda
colon x dot
split
error so let's see the results
so movies
yeah you can see in the Saturn so now
you can see all the words are separated
by comma so now it will easy to match
overview to recommend a particular movie
so moving forward so what we are going
to do is if there is a two word and
space between there so we are going to
remove that space so here you can see
science fiction are separate separate
okay so we are going to re like remove
this one this is space
so let's write code for that
so here I will write like
overview is already done so we will do
not do for that so let's write code for
the rest columns
so here I have to write
movies
like
genres
pursue movies
and again
Jonas
dot apply
amda
X
I dot replace
come on
to no space
oh it seems good
then I have to write for
everywhere so for I in x
it's for I in x 4 I in x
movies genres equals to movie genres dot
apply Lambda X
I dot replace this to this for
Sims code
so let's copy paste this see
one for keywords and one for cast and
crew
asked
first
you
that's the same so let me run this
okay no error seems good
so let's see the changes so movies
so now you can see the science fiction
space is gone like here is science
fiction spaces there
now science fiction space is gone
so like okay
let's move forward and create one new
column name as tag and put all the
column data in a particular column
okay let me do first yeah let me write
movies
this is a column one column name because
two movies
then first we will put overview
Plus movies
and genres
and movies
and what we have to give uh keywords
keywords
then again
movies
then
asked
let me run this
okay
so let's see the data frame movies
okay still coming so like there is one
problem I guess
yeah no no no
so here you can see all the data is
merged in a under attack column yes you
can see like in the second century blah
blah blah so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code
or anything just put as in comment or
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution okay so I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or like any
question just put as in command our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution
so from here let's create a new data
frame
so let me create new data frame because
now we don't need this overview car
screw Joiner like columns like this we
have already merged into a one one
column like attack column so we will
write here new
DF equals to movies
so
like movies we need movie ID
new data frame we need movie ID comma we
need Title
and we have everything in tag column tax
column so we need tax column
okay let's run this let's see our new
data frame
so this is our new data look likes with
only three columns like movie ID title
and tags so here you can see array
brackets like this this area brackets
so
we are gonna remove them so we will do
what we will write here we will write
new
data frame
that n tags
equals to
new
data frame
tags
dot apply
Lambda
X
then I will give space
dot join
themes good everything is okay okay fine
yeah
so let's see the results so
we will write a new underscore data
frame
so you can see the brackets are removed
now let's see the data which is present
in the zeroth index intact column like
this dot dot in this
okay for that we have to write here
a new
data frame
tax
we did it before like for the overview
one so you have to yeah
so this is the whole data in the first
like first index zeroth index so some
part of the overview like from
civilization and some are you can see
this action adventure fantasy science
fiction these are some like genres
and
like here you can see like these are
some Crews members
and
yeah like Sam Worthington like there are
some cast crew okay
so like moving forward like what we are
going to do is just make them in lower
case for the better prediction like
something in capital something like
smaller so let's make it to
lowercase so new underscore DF
tax
equals to new underscore DF
tags
dot apply
column X
dot lower
okay
so don't worry about this error
let's see the result uh new underscore
DF
Dot
yeah now all the data present at TAG
column is in small case or you can say
lowercase moving forward let's do some
feature extraction using count
vectorizer so
let let me write first from SK learn
Dot feature
instruction
feature extraction okay cool
dot text
import
count
vectorizer
DV equals to
count
riser
X underscore
features
equals to
5000.
oh
words
equals to
English
and this
yeah
so count vectorizer
okay there's a
I cannot import count vectorizer from
SQL and from user
okay okay sorry sorry my bad here V is
capital
okay guys so he be his Capital yeah so
no error so count vectorizer is a great
tool provided by the scikit-learn
library in Python it is used to
transform a given text into a vector on
the basis of the frequency count
of each word that occurs in the entire
text so
let me write something CV Dot
with underscore
transform
if
X
like dot to array
shape
okay
so the fit method like learns a
vocabulary dictionary of all tokens in
the Raw documents that is it creates a
dictionary of tokens by default the
tokens are words separated by spaces and
like punctuation so that Maps e single
token to a position in the output
vectors so here CVS are like here CV is
a counter vectorizer so let's convert
into Vector to array so for this we have
to write vectors
vectors equals to CV dot fit
okay then transform
X
in
so here we have to write
Dot
to array
yeah then we have to write
vector
its vectors
yeah you can see Vector 2 array all the
zeros
okay so moving forward let's get the
feature Name by writing
yeah so we will write here
Leanne LAN
CV dot get
feature
names
okay then bracket
yeah
so okay we have like 500 feature names
so I'm repeating I'm saying again like I
hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code whatever it is so
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
okay guys like any code or you are not
understand anything just put as in
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
so let's import some major Library which
is import
nltk
so what is nltk
the natural language toolkit nltk is a
platform used for building python
programs that work with human language
for applying in a statical network
language processing NLP it contain text
processing libraries for tokenization
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning
so moving forward like from let me write
first from
and
nltk
dot stem
dot Porter
import
ER
yes equals to
Tal
I mean is a process for reducing a word
to its word stem that suffix and prefix
or to the roots of words known as Alama
timing is important in natural language
understanding nlu and natural language
processing NLP
so here like I have to write
so here I will write def stem
text
y
equals to
or I in
text Dot split
y dot append
s
dot stem
done
dot join
y
so let's apply this timing to attack
column so here we will write new DF
X
equals to
new
if
tag
dot apply
um
so let's import a cosine similarity from
SK learn so we will write from SK learn
dot matrices
Dot pairwise
import
cosine
underscore see me clarity
okay it seemed good from SQL and
matrices
metrics sorry Matrix Dot pairwise it is
[Music]
pairwise import cosine similarity okay
let's run this no error so cosine
similarity measures the similarity
between two factors
the similarity between two vectors of an
inner product space it is measured by
the cosine of the angle between two
vectors and determines whether two
vectors are pointing in roughly the same
direction
it is often used to measure document
similarity in text analysis so here we
will write
cosine
underscore Simi
clarity
vectors
so these all are the vector present
let's see the cosine similarity Vector
column and row using space
so here I will write cosine
similarity
vectors
dot shape
so it's still running you can see here
yeah
so 4806 rows and four eight zero six
columns are there let's assign variable
similarity to this
okay so let's similarity
will write like this write equals to
cosine
similarity
is underscore here
I did this because we don't have to
write always this long sentence a long
keyword you can say
so moving forward let's see First Column
like we will add similarity
yeah so this is our first column uh so
let's see the rows only so we will write
here
clarity
zero
Dot
shape
okay 4806 okay
so let's move forward and let's create
some like sorted list so
for that sorted
okay
paste
enumerate
spelling is fine
okay one more like Simi laity
similarity
that I have to write reverse
equals to true
comma key
equals to Lambda
colon
x dot capital x x
to write 1
colon six
seems good yeah
so the enumerate function in Python
converts a data collection object into
an enumerate object enumerate returns an
object that contains a counter as a key
for each value with an object making
item within a collection easier to
access so finally let's create the
recommend function to check the movie
recommendation system
okay
so
so let's write here d f
recommend
we
also new
DF
in the TF
title
movie
X
zero
tenses
versus similarity
and movie
okay so movies
list equals to sorted
rate
already and rate
distances
reverse
pursue
true
keyword
sorry key only okay
equals to Lambda
colon X
and
6.
or
I in movies
list
DF dot I lock
I
dot title we because we need Title only
so yeah it seems good okay
so finally that like time is game
so finally the time has come to check
the recommendation of your favorite
movies so you can comment in the chat
section so I can check
so let me write first recommend
recommend for movie
Avatar
okay
so here you can see the recommendation
system is working fine so Titan a DOT e
small soldier Independence Day are the
recommendation for the movie after so
let me check for the another one
recommend
like for
one of my favorite movie Iron Man
so here you can see Iron Man 2 Iron Man
3 Avengers Age of Ultron Captain America
and the Avengers are just
recommendations for the movie Iron Man
so let me check for the one more
recommend
layers
liar
things going on 30 and the last one is
last one I want to check is
Captain America Civil War
let me copy from here only
yeah you can see the Captain America the
First Avenger the Winter Soldier Iron
Man 3 age of ultron's the Avengers with
this we have come to the end of this
fantastic video I hope this video was
informative and exciting if you have any
queries regarding the Hands-On lab
covered in this video or need help
opening for this course please let us
know in the comment section below our
team of experts will happily resolve all
your queries as soon as possible until
next time thank you stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign